hello everyone and welcome to a game
that pretty much just ended uh it's from
the uh simultaneous exhibition unit held
against uh 10 other communities our
community being only one of them
and you guys requested this game because
it's not only a great game to show it's
also a game that you guys played so we
had to decide on the format how are we
going to suggest moves other streamers
implemented this uh technique of
actually having a voting system uh but i
thought that this might be a bit uh too
convenient for someone to check a move
and then just vote for that move so i
thought uh you guys just uh you know
write moves in the chat and i'm gonna
play the one that looks the most
interesting the most daring uh or you
know so it's a it's a combined effort
like uh europe wanted it to be uh but
also i think that
it was the
uh most uh
interesting one or and and also quite
fair
uh so let's see what happened here and
uh how the game went it's uh quite a
short game so i'm sure you guys will
enjoy it so you that has the white
pieces and she opens with e4
as she usually does we played c5 there
was some discussion whether to go for e5
or c5 we decided to go for the sicilian
defense knight to f3 in the knight to c6
there was a lot of discussion and maybe
to play the dragon sicilian uh which
europe of course would enjoy attacking
very much but in the end after d4 unit
goes for the open silence he captures
knight captures uh we decided to go for
this lunatal variation of e5 um it's a
very very interesting way to play
currently not considered all that
impressive for black but
this is what was to the community
decided so knight's the b5 going after
that d6 square and of course d6 now
so playing in the style of morphe versus
anderson uh the kalashnikov variation is
on the board we have c for now you do
the grabs full control over the d5
square and here we decided to fully uh
make the the game explode uh and we
played f5 uh and this is not just uh a
great move uh it's also upon sacrifice
it doesn't have to be but it is it's not
really a great move it's more of a great
move as we wanted to have a really
active position but you did just
captures the pawn and now we played
knight to f6
uh interestingly you could go for bishop
captures on f5 and this is uh sort of
even
encouraged then white continues with
bishop to d3 you can play something like
bishop back to e6 and then the game
continues however we wanted to play the
most uh active way possible in the style
of old master so we played knight to f6
and you did just the defends the pawn
she plays bishop to d3 and what are we
to do now well we chase away units
knight with a6 we have knight to c3 and
bishop to e7 now i know we might even
considering uh consider uh the castle
kings side uh but she just plays g4 she
says all right i invite you to castle
king's side and then you will have to
deal with some consequences later on
uh so uh okay we played h6 uh there was
some discussion of uh maybe playing h5
but h6 uh
keeps the game closed for the moment uh
but also her king is on e1 and if she
castles king's side then uh she might
not be able to attack on the king's side
so comfortably so here she just played
queen bishop to e3 and we after some
discussion decided that it was best the
strike in the center with d5
uh so well usually we say if you can
push d5
as you play the sicilian and not lose
the game you're gonna have a great game
and it seems like the correct thing to
do i mean captures characters captures
captures your queen is nicely
centralized on the e5 you're attacking
the rook on h1 what could go wrong
however after c captures on d5 we played
knight captures on d5 and now the game
is completely winning for you so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for you while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
insta brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course pawn to f6 that's the that's the
stuff uh the idea is that we are pushing
this pawn with tempo and we are
threatening bishop to g6 and bishop to
g6 is uh will just a terrible move for
black to face uh because let's say you
capture this what is the threat well
just bishop to g6 and now you have uh
this knight attacked twice once the king
moves or you play something we just pick
up the knight and that's it we're up a
piece and another thing after f6 what
what else can you do
it's a very very unpleasant you play
bishop to b4 f counters and g7 your
entire position falls apart i mean
there's there's just no way for
for you to play this bishop g6 check is
coming the shop captures an h6 is coming
so everything is falling apart however
you did not play this uh interestingly
after knight captures on d5 she played
uh knight captures on d5 and we just
played queen captures on d5 and this was
uh
yeah much much better than i thought uh
that could happen i did not see the f6
idea some people were writing that she
has f6
in the chat but uh i imagine uh
those were extremely strong uh uh
players in the chat
uh and now it seemed like our position
all of a sudden uh got a lot better we
have a beautifully centralized queen on
d5 we're attacking the rook on h1 once
the rook moves or she castles or or
whatever
we can continue development uh and after
some consideration she uh decided to
castle rook the g1 is the other way to
go uh you still kind of retain the
idea of of just pushing on the king side
but she castled here and now all of a
sudden we felt much much safer but now
it's time to play this precisely and we
continued with knight to b4 we attacked
the bishop here on d3
and now she has to move it bishop to e2
is played uh bishop to c2 also works but
it looks kind of weird putting it on c2
where the knight can capture it so at
least she's up upon at least uh you know
you should keep the bishop pair uh and
now we have to trade here and the game
goes on for example if uh queen captures
on d1 where she has to play bishop
capture sunday one to guard the c2
square otherwise knights the c2 just
picks up the exchange and now we
continue playing this game it's uh not
easy but uh you know it's definitely
something let's say h5 can be played we
want to open up the h5 for our rook she
has to defend captures captures now
bishop d7 we want to get uh something
out of this position now let's say
knight d2 keeping around this f3 square
and the game continues even ideas like
bishop to b5 are in the position now as
the knight is strongly placed here
rookie one knight here we could even
maybe win the exchange after bishop to
f3 let's say knight captures rook
captures and now castles queen side and
white will always be better here the
bishop pair
is incredibly impressive black also has
the bishop paris just that white the
bishop pair is a bit stronger rook and
rook can grab the open c file and c1 so
uh white will be better here but not by
a lot and this was our only way of
playing this and we did discuss queen
captures on d1 uh a lot but then uh
after uh some careful consideration we
decided to play bishop to d7 first we
said okay maybe it's just best for to
allow her to capture our queen and then
we want to put the bishop on this
diagonal as soon as possible but we kind
of overlooked it after knight to c3 now
after queen captures on d1 which is
pretty much forced you don't wanna
put the queen on some silly square and
there there really aren't any impressive
squares after capturing just rook a
captures on d1 now the problem is bishop
to d1 no longer has to be played and now
she has full development uh and now what
do you play here well you could go for
knight c2 which is kind of what you need
to do uh to try and uh re-maneuver the
knight into the game maybe threaten this
bishop a little bit but still she can
play bishop b6 and it's a very very ugly
position for black to play
so instead we played bishop to c6
grabbing hold of this diagonal and now
uh it's a completely winning position
for unit the problem is there's this a3
move and our knight has no square so
rather our knight has the c to square
but that's why she just plays nice to d2
takes away the c2 square from our knight
and now there's really not all that much
we can play if rook to d8 she can just
double up rook after d1 rook captures on
d2 rook captures and after something
like bishop to d7 because we have to
make room for our knight then bishop to
f3 we lose control of this diagonal
and again it's uh much much much better
for for white so instead we played a5
for the lack of a better move just
trying to free up the a6 square for our
knight but now just a3 knight to the a6
and here knight to d5 and there really
is no good move here now our only
counter play was or so we thought as uh
we were down upon we wanted to have our
bishop prepared to be extremely
impressive and her bishop prepared to be
not so impressive but in the end it's
the one the other way around so rook to
d8 was played now rook after d1 and here
we really don't have any more moves we
decided to trade on d5 and here after
rook captures on d5 we gracefully
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here we are down upon we
are losing at least another pawn she can
completely mess up our pawn structure
but also uh what
what can you even play here let's say
you defend this pawn
uh bishop to b5 check is coming where is
the king going king f7 rook to d7 look
at this this completely uh boxes in the
king there's i mean there there is
nothing you can do king goes hero
captures on b7 then the knight is saying
and then this bishop is occupying this
diagonal i mean so many ideas for white
and zero ideas for black so after rook
captures on the e5 on move 23 our
community uh resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so you
can see what uh what an incredibly sharp
line this is and uh yeah even after udit
allowed us back into the game she didn't
play this extremely extremely forcing f6
move uh we failed to
you know take this gift and we
squandered it away blundering the game
terribly in only 23 moves so there you
have it and uh of course you always have
to remember judith wasn't only playing
against us she also uh was playing
against 10 other communities and also
there is a world board uh where the
entire world is playing uh the game is
still going on so i imagine it will be
going on for quite some time as even
after i upload this video so the link to
the game will be in the description
below you can join and input your own
moves so you can be a part of that game
as well as i will probably be analyzing
that game as well so uh thank you all
for joining in thank you for for helping
us uh
try and uh fight you did but as you've
seen that is no small feat she
completely uh destroyed us and uh well
just a very very fine game with white
against the sicilian defense in this
very sharp elemental kalashnikov
variation
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank james mayberry for wishing meadow
a very happy birthday uh team of salo
kojo
and christy maloney for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and continuing of course the
charity cup so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day